Nếu như thực hiện việc xác thực hiện tờ hình dưới lại xuyên bán hàng theo cuối định của lật này,
pháp lột về định dành và xác thực hiện tờ, viên hiền hiền hiền, trước khi cho phát thực hiện là xuyên bán hàng.
Chứ hợp người lại xuyên bán hàng là người nước ngoài thì xác thực hiện tờ hợp pháp,
lột cũng cũng cuối định cụi thế, chắc hiệp của người bán hàng trong hòa đồng lại xuyên.
Cụng theo của định những người lại xuyên bán hàng phải cũng cấp thuộc tên cho đơn vị quần lý này tạng từ ngoài địa tờ.
Để sác thực hiện tính, lòng thời tôn thủ cuối trế hoạt động của người ta.
Chúng không biết bán không cũng cóp đầy đủ hồ xơ, giấy tờ cho phy định,
lần vị quần lý này tạng có chắc hiệp tờ cho phát tạng.
Lột cũng có định người lại xuyên không được lưu ra có tộc viên xây lại hoặc very nhằm lẫn về nổi dùng.
Công dụng, xuất xử, chất lợp, giá bán, chú chỉ quyết mại hoặc chính xác bảo hàng của xan phật, chỉ quốc.
Nổi với hàng ngoài, lịch vụ thuộc dịnh phải xác nhằn lợi dùng còn gáo thì người lại xuyên chỉ được chuyên tài.
Đúng là dùng đặc được cơ quan có tập vui phê dịt.
Được xây dụng, mình ngay một lưới bà chẳng phục trong quá trình phát triệu tiếp, phải phu hợp với thuộc phòng ý tổng,
không chái đặc được xa hội.
Tìa phát hiện bị phạm học theo yêu cầu của các bạn chức năng người lại xuyên phải dừng phát sống,
chấm dứt thật tạc và gửi bò, cận lợi dùng điên quá.